hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the American Cup uh this is
the first game of the Rapids the two
classical games ended in a drone uh it's
Wesley so with white versus Hikaru
Nakamura uh now let's check out the game
and then we're gonna discuss what
happened in the rest of the match so
Wesley has the white pieces and he opens
with E4 uh Pawn to C5 by Hikaru Knight
of three Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
B5 the nismedino rossolimo attack with
Ponte E5 uh of course you can't take
that you could but nothing really good
happens because Queen is seven and then
you just have to give back the pawn so
here Castles by Wesley and Bishop to D6
for the moment uh blocking your Pawn but
by the bishop but this is a well-known
line so of course
um uh Hikaru knows what he's doing so C3
Ponte A6 that should pay for with B5 and
now Bishop to B3 even Pawn to C4 Bishop
to C2 and now Knight to F6 we have Pawn
to D4 striking in the center C captures
on D3 Alpha uh not Bishop but Queen
captures and now Bishop to E7 uh there
are quite a few games where Bishop to C7
was played by Bishop to E7 is a new move
so already now as of move 10 we have a
completely new game uh Bishop to G5 with
the continuous development D6 now uh we
have Rook to D1 and now Knight to H5
offering a trade of Bishops so Bishop
captures with King captures an E7
at uh to help with the defense of the D6
spawn later on you're gonna play some
like Rook to E8 and King to f8 if you
want to artificially Castle uh and pawn
to A4 we say this in pretty much every
video once you see A6 and B5 you play A4
that's just how chess Works Rook the B8
and now a captures a captures and
knights the A3 and this Knight the A3 is
a bit rushed by Wesley a G3 first
stopping Knight to F4 and then uh you
continue with um and Knight to E3 going
after the B5 Pawn uh would have been a
bit better giving kikaru less options
but okay Wesley goes Knight A3 this is
rapid chess Knight to F4 now attacks the
queen queen E3 and queen to B6 now
Hikaru offers a queen trade and already
it's a much different game then you
would have if this Knight was not
allowed on F4 so Knights the D for now
not really a sacrifice because if Pawn
captures then the Knight and F4 is
undefended so Knight characters and d4c
captures and just Rook the d8 now Hikaru
be preparing the castle uh to
artificially castle with king of Faith
Bishop to B3 Wesley shifts the bishop to
this long diagonal and now Bishop to E6
with knifed the C2 adding another
Defender Here and Now King to f8 we have
rooked the D2 preparing to double up on
the D file if needed Rook D to C8
Shifting the Rooks to the C file and now
Pawn to G3 chases away the Knight First
bishop captures on B3 Queen captures and
Knight to E6 again putting pressure on
D4 so Rook 8 to D1 and now Pawn to B for
grabbing more space on the king side
with King to G2 Pawn to G6 and now Ponte
H for end Ponte H5 so locking up the
king side and now Wesley breaks the
tension with d captures on E5 with d
captures and Rook to D7 usually you
don't want to just capture for capture's
sake but here if it gets you the the
seven Rank and the D7 file for your Rook
it's definitely worth it so here Hikaru
plays Rook the C7 but Wesley throws in
an immediate Queen to F3 now Checkmate
is being threatened where he cargo
trades captures captures and now the
only way to stop Checkmate is Knight to
d8 to defend the F7 Square Knight to E3
now Wesley brings the Knight into the
game as well Queen to C6 and now as The
Rook is attacked just Rook the D5 we
have Queen to E6 Queen to D1 now putting
pressure on the Knight on the 8th and
queen to F6 defending we have rooked
back to D7 and now King to G7 uh we
rooked the D6 attacking the queen queen
to E7 and now Rook back to D7 here at
Wesley uh Mrs Queen to D5 Queen to D5
just stops any and all counter play from
black you you really don't have
um
any move here the road can't really move
the back rank because then just a rook
captures on uh and the eight can be
played even if you try to give up a rook
to gobble up White Rock Hikaru has the
uh Wesley has the nice solution to group
captures on G6 followed by Queen
captures on B5 so there's was really
not a good option here and later on you
can play Rook to D7 kick away the queen
put the Knight on C4 gobble up the E5
pawn and so on but okay like I said it's
rapid Rook the D7 was played Queen to F6
and now Knight to D5 this is the plan
that Wesley goes for Queen E6 Knight the
C7 and now Queen to C6 uh here Wesley
offers a queen trade Queen to D5 uh
basically not offers he he forces it
because of Queen captures on F7 so Queen
captures with a queen captures and D5 e
captures and D5 this is how Wesley
creates a past pawn and now Knight to B7
we have Knight the E6 with check King to
G8 and now Knight to G5 putting pressure
on the F7 pawn and Knight to d8 and okay
Hikaru is defending the F7 Pawn but it's
a very very passive position he has to
worry about the the active Rook the
active Knight the pass deep on the soon
to be a very active white king so he's
not just gonna be able to remain there
and do nothing so King F3 we have B3
Hikaru and now King the E4 and here
Hikaru decides that it's definitely time
to to part with the F7 pawn and he goes
Knight to B7
uh but Wesley first uh captures the E5
Pawn as he should and now the king can
also come to F6 with Knight to C5
attacking the rook and here Wesley
should just play Rook captures on F7 but
he doesn't he plays Rook to C7 he
attacks the Knight now Knights the D3
with check King to F6 and now Knight
captures on B2 Hikaru now creates a past
pawn and interestingly there's only one
move that wins the game for Wesley here
and uh well uh if we take into
consideration what was the play it's not
an easy one to find so feel free to
pause the video and try to win this game
for Wesley while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
correct idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is not
Knight captures on F7 this is what
Wesley played uh the move that wins the
game or Rook captures on F7 for that
matter uh the move that uh should have
been played is Pawn to D6 and the reason
is very simple uh because after the
Knight moves clearing the path for the
past B Pawn you just push D7 and there's
no defense against The Rook the C8 the
king covers G7 and the Knight covers the
H7 square but that's the price of Rapid
chess you don't have time to at the spot
uh a little things like that and if Pawn
to B2 like I said this will just be
Checkmate captures captures and that's
Checkmate but instead Wesley played
Knight captures on F7 which okay still
gives white a lot of pressure but it's
just not winning by force Knight the C4
by Hikaru now even offering a knight but
if you capture that then B2 just wins
Knights the H6 with check King to f8 and
now Rook the F7 check the king hunt
begins King 38 with rookie 7 check King
38 Knight to F7 check Hikaru didn't even
want to go back he goes to the queen
side now he wants more than a draw King
the C8 Now Pawn to D6 advancing the pass
Pawn D7 is coming and now in fact if you
play B2 then Rook to C7 is mate in one
so you have to be very careful here so
Hikaru has to move the Rook Rook to B6
the only move that does not lose the
game he has to clear the B8 Square for
the king Rook to E8 with check King to
B7 and now King to E7 you can't move the
pawn while the king is in the same file
as The Rook Pawn to beat you and now D7
and now we get and two more Queens on
the board the B1 queen queen and d8
queen and now Queen to B for check
Hikaru is the first one to start
checking and there's only one way to
handle this and that is Knight the D6
with a counter check and now uh you you
have to trade if you don't trade you're
just lost if you go to A6 uh Queen to A8
is made in one if we go to C6 it's not
much better Queen day 8 with checking
the C5 Rook to see it with check you can
go to D4 but now Queen to e for checking
C3 and The Rook characters and C4 check
will win the black queen captures
captures uh so instead after Knight the
D6 check you have to trade Queen
captures on D6 again with check Queen
captures we have Knight captures on D6
and not Rook to G8 now Wesley uh is down
down a piece but he is up a pawn and
this is not um uh well not easy this is
in fact very very hard to win uh Even In
classical but um uh you know in Rapid
when you play an increment when you have
a few seconds on the clock uh it's a
very much a different story but okay
Knight to F5 checking the E8 and King to
C7 now we have Rook the f8 uh putting
pressure on that night there Knight to
H6 and just Rook the F4 we have rooked
the E6 with check uh King to f8 and now
King to D6 uh we have King to G7 and now
Knight's death 5 with check King F7 the
king to D5 and now Rook the F3 white can
only wait and see what black comes up
with uh Rook to A6 and now Rook the B3
we have King to E4 Rook to C3 Knights
the D6 check and King to G7 we have King
to D4 Rook to B3 Knights the F5 with
track King to H7 and now King to E5 so
trying to box in the white king but
that's easier said than done Rook B8 we
have Knight to E7 King to G7 and now
Rook the A7 threatening a nasty
Discovery here to win the white Rook so
Rook V5 checking to E6 Rook the B6 shot
King to F5 uh Rook B5 checking to G4 and
Rook the B4 check of course Wesley will
check the black king uh as much as he
can to invoke the 50 move rule so King
stage six with Rook to A6 King to G5 now
Knights the D5 attacks The Rook Rook the
D4 we have Knights the C3 King to H6 and
King to G to pawn to G4 now upon move by
Wesley nonetheless we ignite the E to
Rook the B4 and now King to F3 with G
captures on H5 G captures and King
captures on H5 with Knight to F4 with
check King to G5 and now Rook the A5
with check with King to H6 and now comes
King to G4 so now uh it's a two points
and a rook against only a rook and the
Knight so can the two pawns be enough
for uh to counter the Black Knight with
King to G7 King to F5 Rook the B7 and
now Knights the E6 with check King H6 we
have King to F6 and now Pawn to H5 now
you have to be very careful not to get
the checkmated so Rook the A8 going for
Rook to h8 but it doesn't really matter
you always have Rook to H7 Ponte F4 by
Wesley uh we have Rook the h8 with check
you could capture the pawn there's
nothing wrong with that uh Rook the H7
now the rule goes back Rook day 8 and
Rook to B7 now Knight captures on F4 we
have rooked the B6 with check Knight the
E6 uh and now King to H7 we have rooked
the A7 with the check King to H6 and now
Rook to D7 and here uh well it's still a
draw but Wesley has to play uh play
precise moves he has to play some like
Rook to B1 or Rook to B8 or basically
move the Rook anywhere just not what he
played he played Rook captures on E6
thinking that it's a force to draw uh
but it's not Hikaru actually wins this
King captures on E6 King to G6 now it
seems that you're getting your Pawn all
the way to h8 and you will promote it to
a queen but now Rook to D1 Ponte H6 and
Rook the G1 with check and now the
problem is if you go to H5 and you can't
go uh left you have to go right if King
to H5 just King to F5 threatening
Checkmate and once you move the king
king G6 gobbles up the pawn so you have
to go up the board King to H7 was played
but now King to F7 and and he was in
this position and moved 103 that Wesley
so resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once uh uh a king
to F7 lands you have to play King h8
it's your only move and now look at this
Rook to A1 now it doesn't matter what
you play if you push the pawn then Rook
date is Checkmate so of course you're
gonna play King to H7 but now either
Rook the H1 or Rook the A6 rooked A6 is
much nicer I think uh leaving white with
only uh one move King to h8 and now Rook
captures an H6 would be Checkmate so
it's a first Checkmate regardless of
what Wesley does
and that's why after uh 103 moves he
resigns the game so two classical games
end in a draw then then Hikaru takes the
win in the first rapid game but Wesley
retaliates in the second rapid game uh
and then they went into Blitz tie breaks
and once they went in the blitz tie
breaks uh Hikaru just completely
obliterated Wesley uh it wasn't uh I
mean it wasn't even a contest Wesley
just blundered upon in the first game
and then he blundered uh the position
and then he just blundered another Pawn
so and Hikaru took advantage of all of
those uh tiny blunders and uh the second
game not much different
uh so yeah Hikaru wins the finals of the
American Cup a very tough matchup by
Wesley but uh as you've seen the uh as
as uh time format went lower and lower
he calls uh uh string just went um you
know uh up and uh when it came to the
blitz section he was just Unstoppable uh
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it tough luck for Wesley as he
was winning uh in uh in a couple of
instances in the game uh but you know
you only win if you actually win so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank a very nice video
yesterday Ryan Kavanaugh Henry Spraggins
Richard carp and Laurent Andre gianicini
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day